okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel welcome to
episode 12 of the pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos i go live
every
wednesday thursday and saturday and we
do a live show here so subscribe turn on
your notifications so you're notified
every time i go live
just you guys know i will be reading all
super chat so if you guys want me to
acknowledge you if you want your comment
to be read send a super chat i'll read
it
last thing is our sponsor for the
podcast today is cooking with chris he
offers completely custom made meal plans
specific to you i'm actually on his meal
plan right now i've lost 12 pounds in
the last like month and a half so it
actually works it's pretty cool
um i've like struggled with eating my
whole life i'm addicted to sugar it's an
issue and he actually gives food that
like you actually enjoy eating so thank
you guys for coming today thanks for
having us um to start let's go around
one by one say your name and where they
can find you on social media
my name is jordan jordan spencer uh
instagram j.o underscore spencer finally
there
my name is amani you can find me on tick
tock ammani underscore xox
my name is abby you can find me on
instagram rave world w-a-b-e-w-r-l-d-d
if you're into fashion and stuff
my name's josh farm on instagram at
george hibbert
and i'm in zania you can find me on
instagram at zania 13 a-z-a-n-i-a
okay so
today if you guys didn't know i got into
some heat this week people didn't like
my opinions um
because
i said that
if after a woman has kids okay
she's probably gonna gain 10 20 pounds
but i said if a woman gains like a
hundred
pounds
at that point it's a choice and i would
understand if your partner left
what do you guys think would you stay if
your partner gained a hundred pounds
and you everyone you should let the boys
my opinion
is that okay you get married you love
the person as they are ratata but for
example if i was in that boat this is me
speaking of a man who whatever if i put
on a hundred pounds and my wife has not
told me in the process like yo you need
to fix up
i would take that as in like yo she's
looking after me my health is not right
but if you put on a hundred pounds
something's gone wrong like
so you're just saying it for like not
the visual for health benefits no that's
for sure but not like
bro
yes
that's a lot of weight you're worried
about our health
no
first of all dude
a less fiery perspective first but then
visually yeah like
if i if i put 100 pounds of fat like i'm
just like maybe her cooking is fire or
something hundred pounds
that's that effort to put on that much
weight we're not like
um
after pregnancy postpartum depression
that's that's what i said though i said
i don't understand 10 20 pounds
and i don't think i don't think men
should just like give you no warning and
up and leave
but at some point it becomes a choice
yeah if you're gaining fifty seventy
thousand a hundred okay go ahead there
are some relationships that they feed
their partner because they like them
bigger yeah yeah
obviously
like a bigger guy than like
that's calm but like if you're if that's
not your type
and maybe like you would say your type
is more
what athletic or cyan
and she strays away from that like
where i kind of like your point in the
fact of um
that if if she or he whatever hasn't
come up to you and said look you're not
looking trim how i first met you what's
going on then and if you're official
what like say for example it was my if
it was just like your boyfriend yeah and
they put 100 pounds would you stay with
him
i'm saying he's not committed though
like it's like true difference if you're
married or if you're if you're
um
i mean women leave all the time like
women leave the majority of
relationships and they'll leave for
things for like not being happy
you know not like they need to define
themselves things like that which is
which is fine i think you can leave for
whatever reason but like sexual
attraction is part of a relationship i
think it's important when people don't
say it's like the first thing that like
oh [ __ ] over personality that's
right you'll see that you need to look
at this person you're ironic about yo
this is like a bad b like on a regular
afternoon of course doesn't mean that
someone wouldn't cheat or something
won't do this it's like it's a start
because other [ __ ] [ __ ] up
relationships regardless but do not
think like see like river marriage i
think that's like a completely different
ball game so
like you've you've bonded on a different
level so we've gone past like attraction
at this point like we've actually
blended like intellectually
finished let me finish like we've gone
past like that attract like there is
attraction don't get existed like that's
so important but there's that
intellectual spiritual like emotional
like
that other all types of different
connections like to the point like i
like personally that i'm gonna encourage
you first but you're a girl i'm going to
ask the guys does it start with the
visual or does it start with the mentals
what by the time you're married have you
have you guys been in love before
okay
even when you were in love did it still
start with the visual or the mental yeah
because it's like
no matter what happens when it like
you're going to speak to someone or like
however it starts it's starting for a
reason and it's not
a lot of times it's not starting because
you're like
i think we're going to have really great
conversations like it's done because
it's like
she's attractive
i want to know more even like the most
innocent people i feel like when they
start to see someone they were like look
and be like oh they're attractive let me
go and find out more like let me chat to
them like it's never going to be like
well let me just chat for no reason i'm
not saying sparks
so so
i'm gonna ask the girls
do you think that's wrong do you think
it's wrong for a guy to leave his wife
if she lets herself go and i'm not
talking about
a little bit of baby weight i'm talking
about 100 pounds
50 50 plus that's like 45 kilos for the
british for the british followers here
i love that
and and on the same note if your partner
gained that much weight would you stay
or go
i'm gonna try and motivate him so
i'm not gonna leave just because of that
i'm gonna say
hey let's go to the gym together let's
go
say that again say it again no i'm
saying like it's just funny the way you
say it's like
i'd be like yo
you've been putting on weight or like
she i'd expect her to be like yo
you've been putting on weight
she went to the gym together
but i think that's a conversation you
have prior to saying oh let's go to the
gym like
i'm assuming that you black okay let's
have a conversation about it so there's
some back story to that like let me let
me ask the men your previous girlfriends
how do you think they would respond
if you said
that they'd been gaining weight and it
was a problem
that's a mad conversation like a mad
conversation she could actually be cool
because she told me she tells me my [ __ ]
stinks all the time like something about
me like you know what i mean like
i don't take it personally me like i
just think regardless if you don't know
i just think like for me like just even
to say that would be on my conversation
like okay there's another wedding day
and she comes down right now like she
asks
behind the scenes like bedroom talk like
babe it's not like you're out in public
like yo but if you're big right so like
pay me the situation
you have to be in but you know what i
mean there's behind closed doors just
having this like and how does that
conversation go like you're gaining
weight like how does that go
so yeah i think i think you've been
putting on weight right
eating all the pies like i just don't
get it right let's put this less i've
been feeding you then like we've been
getting
i just think i would want to help him
more like i don't know if that's rude
you guys think that's rude but
as your partner i agree with you yeah
if you're in it for a long run and
you're together
yeah you're gonna have to give them
options right and try and help
themselves i think it's different from
okay not a gym but like hey should we go
for a walk tonight yeah you might stay
with a little man if you put a hundred
pounds on them yeah like your man say
your ten years
marriage
like you'll be like is this kids as well
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
is like an option for me
i'm trying to motivate him to do other
things and then if he's not motivated
then that's when i'm leaving
okay so you would leave yes after
after
like i said you said i'm gonna do
everything i can to motivate them now
i'm gonna have so many conversations
that i'm gonna know i tried my best
because i committed to this marriage for
better for us sickness and health
everything like
it's like why am i gonna just up and
leave like over it i know like we're
gonna keep trying
and then if to the point they said like
they're actually not even trying to help
themselves because i can't help you if
you don't wanna help yourself and we've
tried so many times i've put in a lot of
effort i've gone out my way
then we're gonna have a conversation and
i'm gonna say do you know what this
isn't working like because
each person is entitled to fool to want
what they want to be attracted to what
they want yeah and be like whatever
makes them happy that's their
prerogative somebody said 60 pounds
60 pounds of muscle yeah that's tough
but
i've got a membership to pure gyms
so what would you prefer to be in fat
you'd prefer to be a muscle yeah that's
different for women though yeah
yeah it's competitive okay
yeah we're talking about fat though
again muscle
above 60 pounds of muscle or what
she smells of fat no but like you know
you don't know what you're looking at
anymore
i think we're all leaving but not
like i feel like it's very disrespectful
it depends on the person obviously like
to just up and leave like oh yo like
your mind's got put on weight and then
you're just out like that's your husband
like you've been feeding somebody into
that no i wouldn't do it and then when
you really could like leave your kid if
you could put something
like it's just my okay it's different
no but it's like but like when you look
at marriage you're leaving you'll keep
like that's putting your kids like you
have to like assess every situation and
all the like consequences of that for me
i think it depends on if there's kids
involved or not
so do you guys think if there's kids
involved you should stay through
everything
like the weight gain that's like i could
put that aside but there's other things
that i wouldn't say what about so i
would say like the male equivalent of
that is what if he was just being a bum
like he lost his job he's not working
not trying to work
okay so if he's not financially
supporting me and the kids yeah and he's
not helping around the house no just
being a bum oh god um because that's
kind of like the the female equivalent
because people are different right
i feel like if it's come to a point like
obviously i'm going to say i'm going to
try to help you get a job try and pick
you up and put you back up there but if
you're not trying to help yourself then
i'll probably leave you probably so it's
interesting because i'm telling you when
i put this like on my instagram i got
like so much blow back but when i'm i'm
talking to a conversation with like
people that haven't even really watched
the show and you all kind of have the
same view on it right yeah um
what the pregnancy
okay question for the men okay do you
guys think do you think that girls
sometimes let themselves go after they
get it rang and or they get into the
relationship that they were wanting
[Music]
i think it's just personal like yeah
i've never really thought like a girl's
like you know what i'm a person waiting
on because i got him now like it just no
i don't really choose to do it but
sometimes like oh they're just oh
they're comfortable because i already
have my amp type thing when you say
sometimes like as a as a couple they put
on weight like
sometimes it just happens they'll be
going out to eat all the time
i get surprised when i see some people
that are one way one time and then like
they got so big i'm like yeah well i
think that's just like perth like
personality like
i think that's just personality
agreed
sorry there's some people are
complaining about the sound in the chat
i think i fixed it though
[Music]
i think it um be mine i'm trying to
because it sounds okay on my end but
we'll see
um okay bit more interested in that
um
do you want am i allowed to read in
there no oh you can just try not if as
long as it's not distracting you oh it
wasn't yeah the muscle um
it's not my podcast you know i mean i
gotta stay in my lane how dare you body
shame these queens
um okay
is
do you think it's wrong to leave a
family if you're not happy
for the like at the time can i ask
following questions or what do you mean
by leave a family so
you're
you're in a relationship and you have
kids sorry it's distracting me but this
right here
oh no no bring it back he said the
relationship um the relationship my wife
had before me she gained 100 pounds then
lost it all then we met then she gained
100 pounds again then divorced me
wow
that's an interesting perspective
yeah so do you guys think it's okay to
leave a relationship or a family if
you're not happy so if you have kids
getting a little help
also guys let me know in the chat what
mic is like off because i keep saying
that a mic is off and i'm not sure which
one it is um so let me know which one
and i'll see if i can fix it but i think
these three are okay so i think it's
either mine or yours
but go ahead are you leaving
[Music]
wait are you down here are you new here
like if you haven't
[Music]
but it's not going to be the same for
the kids like there's nothing like
happening i've been unhappy for
a year
just like
a conversation and it's still not
working like but why am i in my
conversation
i guess they're going back and forth and
it's working out and you keep arguing
for a year yeah i think if like you're
not happy yeah i think i think it's fine
for either party to leave if like the
boy isn't happy i need like three
conversations i think a lot of plushies
because of the kids that will make sure
you like
we tried to choose didn't work cool
that's three three situations okay
i feel like when it comes to kids you
have to kind of think about them as well
because
like a lot of kids come from families
that don't have like me i came from a
family that didn't have two parents and
growing up like that is like
growing up like that it's kind of um
like a disadvantage so loads of things
in life and i'm just like if i have kids
i feel like
sometimes i may put them first like
until they get to like around the age of
18 i might put their feelings first and
they're like i'll try to make it work as
much as i can with my partner but i'd
rather us be living in the same
household and like for the kids
that affects you as a parent like see
how i think of it is like okay cool
we've tried everything yeah we've had
everything to make it work okay we're
actually unhappy for one to three years
and then
is it working yeah so i'm going to make
a quick change so i'm going to take off
your mic and you two are going to share
because i think this is picking up the
echo and i haven't
yeah so you two are just going to go
back and forth sorry
um
okay but yeah go ahead go ahead yeah so
i so i just feel like
um for me to be the best person i can
for my
for my kids is like
i need to be like a better person for
myself and if i'm unhappy like i feel
like that shows him with my relationship
with my kids that they're going to see
it in the house they're going to sense
that i just i think so why am i just
trying to please them and give them
false hope and we could really prepare
them and have certain conversations with
the kids because it's like not
everything does work out hunky-dory and
you can have two parents that live in
the same household like we could me and
my partner could really co-parent if we
have the open communication but the
problem i just feel like when you have
kids it's not about you anymore like
it's not it's not about your happiness
it's about the kids and i think like
it's women mostly like leave
relationships if you're college educated
you know what your chance of getting
divorced is if you're a girl
[Music]
no no you're gonna leave 90 like you if
you get divorced and you're college
educated
women only leave ten percent of the time
or they leave ninety percent of the time
remember
yeah that's a statistic yeah and it's um
it's seventy depending on the source
seventy to eighty percent of the time in
just normal relationships like women are
the ones leaving not men
but like i feel like women often like
leave because we're not happy for like a
short period of time so thinking of like
the long term
yeah but i think men are weak i think
men are weak
one at a time shots fired but i think
men are weak in the fact of
like they're happy to stay
like if they just maybe if
i don't know like why would they be
happy to stay no no no no no no but
you're not able to come to the table and
say i'm not happy so instead you step
out
of life i don't think i think a lot of
men struggle to say that in general or
to hurt her feelings somebody that you
love and then to say look i'm not really
happy but then what you do is you go do
something dumb and then you get yourself
in trouble so then she leaves you
and you don't leave the situation hence
why that statistic is so high i think
men are just dumb in a lot of situations
so it's not like they but when's enough
enough like you lot of humans your
brains are very smart and it's not okay
to be like and then you're just dumb you
sound dumb saying that just excuse me
i don't mean it like that i'm sorry
so so if you're gonna talk into that mic
like grab the stand and just pass it
between the two of you does that make
sense i can make this longer sorry we
got issues today
go ahead okay
so the original question stay there
again please no i'm not gonna have to
think of this so no the original
question is
like it's like when you have kids is it
about your happiness or is it about the
kids happiness
i think it kind of can play a role as
water because if
you stay together you could actually be
bringing out more of a toxic environment
so if you stay together with like pure
arguments right our life
it could end up just getting like and i
guess if it is
toxic like that naturally it can get
like i guess a bit manipulative it's
just like power
maybe if you break up it might be a
better relationship actually might be
better for the kids if you actually
separate because you can then
live a better life as a as a
can i follow up on that i agree with
what he said because i feel like also
like even when you bring up your kids in
that environment you're kind of showing
your kids what they're going to want to
accept in the future like personally me
like i want to show my kids
like a way of living and i feel like
if i'm showing them that yeah i'm
staying in like an unhappy relationship
because they're going to sense it we all
live in the same house like how are you
not like my kids aren't going to be
stupid
like so for me it's like i'm showing
them oh it's okay to stay in an unhappy
marriage but i don't want my kids to
feel like just because you're obliged to
your kids like because you could really
teach their moles like just because
we're co-parenting and we're separated
or divorced et cetera doesn't mean but
you really statistically like how much
of a disadvantage you are if you don't
have both parents in the house
even if you are dividing that really
good yeah like you're still at a
disadvantage because it's not the same
no it's like but i'm gonna be honest i
don't i don't i don't i don't know them
like these stats off the top of my head
but like you're much more likely to
commit a crime if you're not raised with
both parents in the house you're much
more likely to drop out of school like
every stat that possible like i promise
if you spend five minutes researching
this like
is
it says it's better to have both parents
in the house
so entry
you're you us but i would be shocked if
it's different here i would be
shocked but then statistically more
people get divorced in the u.s than the
uk in general like is that true for sure
do you think it's because less people
get married here
do you think because because um the
average age of first marriage in the uk
is 31 where it's 27 in the us for women
anyway
i just
30 31
in the uk for average age of first
marriage well i i know obviously i'm not
statistic i don't know if it's like
taken into account because obviously
like if it is a broken home it could be
possible like
one of the parents might be just gone
john saying so like all the people that
maybe like
are living like the single pair of life
obviously maybe that is a disadvantage
but
the if the both parents were there
contributing like i'm being i guess
being role models in that way
i feel like
maybe the statistics won't reflect that
as such
um i mean it probably i'm sure it's
better like
if the dad or the mom like whatever one
is out of the house like is in their
life but
i just can't imagine a world where like
it's better to have
them in separate houses than into one
like it doesn't mean the child's like
doomed it can't do anything it's just
like if you leave you're putting your
kids at every statistical disadvantage
possible
and it's for what you for your happiness
but you're supposed to love your kids
more than you like if we're in a
relationship and we're not happy i feel
like the thing that we could agree on is
our children's happiness and we're going
to try to figure out stuff for our
children's happiness yeah yeah that's
what that's the relationship but then
also it's like you have to at what point
you consider your own happiness you have
your own one life like honestly huh of
course you have your kids no listen but
it's not that they're gonna be
like it's not like the world is at end
like they can't move on you have your
mom you have your dad they're not
together but like but like which is a
lot more staying together and you're
unhappy on a daily basis with someone
that is obviously the reason you're
unhappy with them they've ever hurted
you or like hurt you know her
[Music]
man i ever heard you're like something's
happened to cause like this rift in
like seriousness but do you think that
possibly like it's something that you
yourself have to work on because it
takes two in a relationship
so if you're arguing all the time like
it takes someone to argue with of course
but you'd be unhappy in something in the
situation not about yourself you'd be
like because that's something you would
address with your partner like oh i
don't like this about myself or i don't
think like they would argue about yo
you're not doing this or
i could plug it i'll get to them
you'll get like we'll get mad pet people
like when you don't like something about
someone else if you really care about
someone you're like i have like you
don't want to see them angry at you you
put your own i've been in society at the
start yeah but obviously like if we're
talking about what happened with
something about doing this for 18 years
above being unhappy for 18 years that's
the 10 year 10-year hits from like it's
mad bro like man's arguing about the
craziest things that's uh
craziest things like things are so
irrelevant 10 years in your life like
i just don't think things are forever
like i think it shouldn't be like
yeah marriage for well seriously i think
like at five
i think no no no i mean more in the fact
of like every five years like kind of
sit down kids are involved or not just
like are you happy can i do anything
more what is what's good in our
relationship what's bad in our
relationship this whole
happy forever is just a perfect thing
it's a fairy tale i've been married i've
i've been married
i believe in it yeah and i tried to stay
in my marriage so and would i get
married again absolutely so i'm saying
would you think like you just said like
as in like you wouldn't stay with that
person like you made it sound like you'd
rethink like no i just think no i'm
saying i'm saying conversations yeah i'm
saying in a marriage and any even in a
relationship doesn't even have to get to
a marriage point even with your
girlfriend you're free four five years
in and you're like
you know and i think this is a nice way
for men to come to the table like
actually you're not doing this how you
used to or and this is the comfortable
bit or i would like you to do this oh i
really enjoy this we need to go on dates
more we need to go out like i think
that's where the comfortable bit comes
in of the years you start to lose
yourself you gain a hundred pounds never
gonna happen
is a part of your routine like it's a
part you wouldn't get that unhappy
before you i think that's why she's like
emphasizing on that comfortability so
she's saying like going into that like
in the process of going into marriage
and even after marriage like 10 years in
like continue having those conversations
because it's good to be updated
how your husband or wife feels um like
what they think and what their where
their thoughts are because you know as
people we actually we evolve each day we
evolve like ev all the time so maybe my
likes have changed maybe my dislikes
have changed so i think it's good to
like have those open conversations i
have that open line of communication
that's why the real question is are like
humans like should they be with like one
person oh yeah like yeah you know back
in the day that's not that's how life
was
no that's not how life was that's how
humans have evolved well you know his
traditions have changed but but it's
kind of but it's moving back you know
like
a relationship well you know it used to
be like polygamy used to be the norm
where it would be like a very small
percentage of men would have multiple
wives
it switched to monogamy but that was
that was later but now we're starting to
see the trend go back where it's like a
smaller percentage of men with multiple
girls or women what
why does it have to be men well because
because women are more selective than
men
they can still have multiple partners
well they can but um
but i'm just saying the name put on it
like use it as a hoe
that's the label you're choosing to
everyone
but but again we can't we can't get rid
of our biological differences and men
men biologically had to ensure paternity
so there's a reason they're disgusted by
multiple partners with a woman because
historically if there was a girl that
was sleeping around he could not ensure
paternity and you can't make that even
though it's not even though it's not
like
even though even though even though it's
not it's not like we don't like it and
it might it's probably not convenient
today because most of the girls you like
are probably attractive and they
probably have had multiple partners but
like
but but what i'm saying is like even
though it's not like fun they can't they
can't and women they can't completely
yeah they can't get rid of their biology
we're women we what we're attracted to
is like status you know height success
money
reliability
but statistically
that was she he ate
on my shoulders
it's a stereotype but if we lived in a
life where everything's just a
stereotype it's like what's the point
because there's an exception there's an
exception to every rule but even you
like you realize like 95 of couples the
woman is shorter than the man like
that's that's very much an exception i'm
like
off the richter scale right six foot
four i'm not what are they called
no
what are you talking about like secure
it yeah when you don't pick the one
result because it's like so out there
yeah i'm that person
yeah
i do but she was
she was saying like she doesn't date
shorter guys but then i said your
percentage second yo same with guys like
yo i don't date a white girl black girl
like this is it like that's what you say
do you date uh taller if she was back
yeah yes but then when it comes to
certain topics
no
[Music]
i'm attracted to you but
you know [ __ ] on that defense
yeah
she's more into like mindsets and stuff
yeah i am
did her two her last two boyfriends did
they look like
no no not at all okay okay
completely like on different opposite
sides of the spectrum like mindset
personality like actually maybe not
certain things but yeah a lot of things
were different
solely be physical
we're saying like how tight we're saying
like how tight but you're saying like
your type can be
like a characteristic like just your
type doesn't have to be honestly how you
don't know that until you're attracted
to someone but that's what i mean i
could just see attraction is physical
like a stereotype
but i can be attracted to different
things just like you might like
different types of journals of movies
right like why does that matter but men
and women are different like that's the
thing like like for you guys it's
physical like it all starts with
but who who has dated an ugly guy that's
funny yeah yeah
like a guy could be ugly at first sight
but you get to know that yeah
it makes it interesting your mindset is
one mindset
hold on that sounds like somebody see i
feel like with the ugliness [ __ ] i feel
like that's just
like put that word to the side like you
can actually like create not clear
attractiveness but attractiveness can
grow on you it's what we're trying to
say
like i can be attracted to someone i
bought their personality is so whack
that it's lame as [ __ ] and then it's
like what's what's there for me yeah
like you might not have like you know
get with them whatever but you're
because i could see someone on the
street someone that you're not being
like oh i like them so then you like
them because they're funny and then you
have no intercourse which is like the
most intimate thing but you can't build
sexual attraction but you are hanging
out it doesn't just like you'll make me
laugh and then i sleep with you it's not
like you're going on daylight you like
how they are as a person but like you
don't have that yeah but here's the
thing like women are different we look
for different traits and if a guy makes
you like i can't remember what it is
biologically but if a guy makes you
laugh it shows social status and women
you don't have a blue check mark
right does that help you get girls
i'll go go i'd like to speak on his
behalf
he doesn't want to answer this question
okay but before before right before you
were dating does that did that help
a blue check mark
basically like he wanted to get blue
checked
and like he had to go through the
process whatever and he said after that
his dms were like heavy a lot and that's
what i'm saying because women women
value social status so like historically
if um
mine's dry because men and women
because again
because men and women are different men
don't do you guys care if a girl is a
check mark
no yeah
but but women do because historically
it's it's pre-selected
where's my dna
i'm off the market i'm off the map yeah
but i'm saying like like men and women
are different so historically women um
if someone else was had selected the guy
then that showed that he could take care
of other women so that's pre-selection
it's social status sociology
baby that's why i like that
that's that's why it's a double standard
for like men and women like a guy can
have many girls and more girls will want
him but if a guy a girl has many guys
it's like they don't want her i just
think like
but as women i think we need to do
better i think this comes with age
obviously i'm a little bit older than
you guys
27 um i'm 33. um now a day older yeah
thank you
um 35 shut up 16.
[Music]
no but this is a little thing
as women i think it does come with age
and stuff like that but like
um for women not to sleep with married
men like or men with
in a relationship if you know do you
know what i mean if it's on your
instagram whatever if it's a secret and
he's acting like i'm single blah blah
blah then okay so as a woman i feel like
we need to stop going i know you're
about to hit me with a stat so just one
second and then um and then as women in
relationships when a man does step out
or gets 100 pounds and we shouldn't
really stay either i think as women we
because we're afraid of a man meaning
if if i cheat i know my shit's gonna be
on the front door he doesn't have that
same
stress and fear that we do you know what
i mean so he we have to teach this fear
it's true i know i just see him doing
like he's about to say but you know if
we if we then change the script of the
fact of if we didn't cheat and we kept
him you know i mean accountable and had
gave them that fear if you knew that
your [ __ ] was going to be on the front
doorstep you would act so different
pattern but can i also say i think that
also depends on the woman so for example
like some women i think teach their man
to kind of
like they allow that man to feel like
they allow their partner sorry to feel
like that a lot of stuff can slide so i
feel like once you condone a lot of
stuff like even the small stuff it
doesn't matter because their mind gets
to build that comfortability with them
to think do you know what i can step out
i can't do all of this and it's okay
because i know my woman ain't going
nowhere but i think i feel like it's how
you discipline that but the problem is a
guy has to earn that
where women like women can just cheat
being a girl but like men has to like
it's almost i don't know we just have to
live with these stereotypes that
everyone's complaining about but like
naturally
people go along with like for example if
a woman cheating on a man in a
relationship yeah he's got he might know
that's quickly
if a guy cheats on a woman there's a lot
of possibilities that she's going to
stay regardless that's what i'm saying
is where we have to flip it no of course
we're in this progressive stage that
we're trying to change it but like we're
still living by the same [ __ ] i don't
care what no one says in 2020
girls are still like i'm gonna say curls
but
hoes are still acting the same like
there's a lot of [ __ ] but the problem is
like like
if if you can cheat in the girl stays
that means you're not easy to replace
because it's harder it's harder for a
girl
no no but i'm saying like like
like the reason girls stay is because
the guy's not replaceable the way she
would leave
no i think that's sort of like also
comfortability and feelings that i think
they're like that too i feel like a lot
of women like you can actually be you
can be weak by the fact that like with
the man that you're in love with whereas
with guys i think it's a lot of like
more to do with pride like women can let
a lot of stuff like they can they think
long term they've bigger picture
like you know okay cool but we can work
on it whereas with men it's it's a pride
thing like you really stepped out of me
they will break they will leave the girl
and still be unhappy that they left the
girl but they have to hold it down okay
but
do you i'm not wrong do you think do you
think that cheating is different for men
and women yeah
it shouldn't happen
talk about the master lock and the key
you want that theory speak up about
women have it easier let me hear it
listen
obviously i can't say for all women in
our situation but obviously like
some women like you obviously see it's
in the media or
we
whatever
a madness yeah and it's like
there's always these feelings and all
these raw tartar comes out in the
situation men do it like oh he's a dog
he's this and that but women do like the
same goodness and it's all about all
that they're in a bad situation are
their feelings this mando on instinct
it's sad it's sad and it's not an ex
it's like double sound we're living in
but guys don't like if they cheat on
someone it's not like oh damn i'm in
love with this girl it's like you can go
back the next day and it's like this is
this is the person i love it's a woman i
love however when a girl does it like we
well
stereotypes or conversation like it's
the emotional part first before it's
like yeah i'm trying to get some like
they'll be like they'll be like is that
is that the thing i know like i'ma ask
i'm gonna ask you a lot like all of you
you clearly you know you lie
telling us
i've never cheated i want you
but it's like can i just ask you
for women as well i feel like it could
be on instincts as well because in a
moment she might just be
like horny yeah and a drunk man out yeah
she could be hauling her girls yeah yeah
she would never be my wife she could
never be my wife if she could be on a
night out and she can retweet retweet
read she can be horny on a night out and
she can get chopped she will never be my
girlfriend but a guy can what about a
guy
not you but like a guy could do the same
thing oh yeah so why is that okay in a
men's mentality why is it okay for guys
to think that okay cool i can step out i
can be on a lads night out i can do all
of this and it's okay
but it doesn't make it okay but again
we're biologically different like matt
well i mean
i'm the host
yeah have you guys ever hooked up with a
girl that was like kind of ugly like you
kind of regretted it the next day
like and it was no feelings it was just
like
that's a yeah so unsupported
to be honest like in history like
i've never done one of like regretted
like there's something like
he just looks wise though
no never done what i've like regretted
like
but like the one was like
it's not my best moment
yeah but never never regretted one like
but but like there was there was a
respect level to make the list yeah but
girls don't
but i'm saying like
i was just meaning like metaphorically
like two are you sure yeah yeah are you
positive just like i would say i'd like
to say like a go through a reasonable
level
but the thing is like like women don't
have it like that like if a dude cheats
she just has to be like hot and there
like if a girl cheats he said that'll be
funny and ugly
no funny funny and ugly guys have to
play the long game that's not
no one night snapping anyone
even if that like i think they get
excited as well like you know you could
give them like a chance and then they
get excited like thinking they actually
like
the chase yeah
no but see with them i think they get
excited like they don't have to keep
chasing like they think once they've got
you like say a funny and ugly guy chase
like
until he gets me saved actually in a
relationship i think he gets too
comfortable and thinks you know what
maybe he's out of my league and i'm like
no like you need to stop being original
like he's on my leash like
you realize you realize men tend to date
hotter and hotter because like again
women value social status so if like
like how many girls creep on the
ex-girlfriend
like see what she looks like but like
women do that as a form of pre-selection
because they'll say
what i'm saying like it's a form of
pre-selection so like if i see that a
guy had this this hot of a girl then a
girl
my girl
is that you know what i mean i've never
said yo this guy's not hotter than him
so men like like women
tend to like date date down after where
like men tend to like they date up and
because again like women have a long
laundry list of [ __ ] they have to like
that guy has to have in order for them
to sleep with them or men it's like
short hot available there
well i mean loyal like whatever there's
more but like it starts there where
women it starts with like a way bigger
list we'll start with the head council
[Music]
but i feel like uh what if the guy's
girl is hot and then whoever he's
stating it or sighting is ugly then she
thinks she's
that was the no
that was the worst though when i
realized i had to be worried about ugly
girls too
but because again like like men have a
lower requirement but like they'll have
they'll usually guys like let's say
seven or above they'll take as their
girlfriend but like five or above
they'll sleep with oh five nine six
six six
[Music]
depends on defensive
am i wrong you guys are guys do you
agree with me or not just take the mic
my girlfriend is beautiful
but somewhere in the past
sweet is she watching
yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah i love her
wait so do you do you agree with what i
said because you're single right
yeah what was it wait i need i need to
hear peace
peace to questions like like there's a
certain level that men will sleep with
versus putting like be the girl oh yeah
it's not like yeah yeah like
i've heard like you hear like people
that would mess around with someone
that's uglier than their girlfriend
and this is what i'm saying the reason
when guys see what someone's not like a
oh i think she's a it's more like the
feeling like
i don't condone i don't condone it no
because it is it's like you're you're
reacting off of like a feeling or emotes
like in that moment not like you're
because if you came to your senses like
yo i have my girl at the crib
everything's good like why would i mess
that up then like before you like you
wouldn't do the same thing well they're
different as well like from what you're
talking about there's different uh
like
they like the plan is different john's
saying like let's say if it's often off
if it's off for nine hours so enough
it's off like a one-time thing like the
objective
is very different to say like let's say
your wife and someone like that girl's a
representation of you so like
leave with your best foot forward you're
not saying where if it's like something
else like
the objective might just be to like have
sex so like
you know i mean like the parts needed
for that is a lot less than needed to
represent you in the best way to be your
wife
okay i have have any of the girls on the
panel my girls never admit this
but but
have any of you cheated before
[Music]
no no be honest no no honestly no no
i've had an open relationship
where i'm allowed to see other people is
that you know
yeah
okay so it was innovation you guys spoke
about it like you had a conversation
then you cheated on
we were young and
we couldn't really see each other so it
was like okay let's have an open
relationship but we had to tell the
other person if you'd like if you'd like
and you guys told each other everyone
i never told him and i fell in love with
somebody else
and this is why cheating is different
from men that's why but is that cheating
because she was in an open relationship
it wasn't technically cheating
but then i just
i was in love with two people at one
time which was really weird yeah and
then i went with the other one which
which is fair because that's like when
you're in a place open relationship plan
in the back of your head when you've
agreed to that you have like that you
always acknowledge the possibility
you can fall in love with it
you said you never said that you said
this is me in my 20s right 21 22. yeah
this is the perfect time to do it um no
i'm kidding um wait and so you didn't do
that at the olympics what are you doing
stupid take a whole pass if you make the
olympics guys
the village like everyone was just they
gave out free condoms like everyone's
just trying to [ __ ] everyone well it's a
lot of sexy people in one place and a
lot of male 1 testosterone and sexiness
in one spot i mean i'm not going down to
the shop at end i might stick around
like gymnastics or like
like a little track and field yeah i
mean but even i feel obviously shot put
yeah but everyone's
somebody's trust is somebody's treasure
hundred pound a pound yeah
views and now they're beholden there you
go
you said you're staying with someone
that's a hundred behind you i don't
think you understand a hundred pound is
like
but some people like that's to you but
that's not the guy you fell in love that
you knew like it's not but that's what
i'm saying people evolve like everyone
changes that you evolved into a [ __ ]
yeah
so why can't i evolve to like that i
feel like she could yeah awesome do you
know okay go say it she could evolve to
like i can't evolve to like that what if
i do like see my likes and just like it
changes like all the time like with diff
like the different people i date like it
changed for him like you didn't like
that first now it's like i love this guy
so much i would like starting like
balloons like what's wrong with that no
that's just there's nothing wrong with
that it's just like he's not healthy it
was not real like like you're just like
this is what girls do and i think it's
our natural instinct because we want
people to be like included but like like
come on body positivity you're not going
to be attracted to this the guy the same
100 pounds that's just comments
spoke about i don't know
like this is just and this is like i
don't know why as girls like we because
you're smart yeah i know you know that's
not real like i i know like like in your
little she's saying oh she thinks it's
right like this is gonna be okay
you're smiling because you know
that's my husband like we're gonna work
through that you said 10 years
you're not going to be attracted to it
make it make sense make it make sense
necessary yo they need your help right
now you can't even help them
being on a dummy
is it weird to hear a girl say these
points yeah
no because i know what her point is i
don't know mine oh yeah
so normally we're in the back end like
but generally i never said like i agreed
with zlatan when he was like we'll leave
but i thought i'd do the most to make
like to try
and like change that lifestyle right but
you're you're kind of switching what you
see yeah i just said to you i was like
yo it was ten years that deep and they
got fat and you know yeah this is what
girls do too instead of saying it to
everything that is private
this is where girls like we move the
goal post and that's what you do what's
wrong with that well it's fine but like
like instead of just saying like like
that's what you did we moved the goal
post
like it can be but you but you know what
i'm saying like we're on the same
wavelength okay i i think right because
you're you're smart i know you're smart
so i we were we were having the
conversation we were talking about if
you can gain a hundred pounds and still
be attracted to them and before you were
arguing that you could be and i was
saying that's not real and now you're
saying like now you're changing it no
i'm like
if we're going back to the earlier
conversation i did say yeah i can today
but i'm saying if like we're having a
conversation and i'm still unhappy like
i'm doing everything to help you yeah i
also did say out loud i was like i will
leave eventually like because we've done
everything we've had so many
conversations we've tried for so long
like it's actually unhealthy my question
was if you've been with someone for 10
years and they go over you said yeah
like you would say whatever you think
it's all that's interesting no but this
is after we've had the conv the whole
debate like
in the first instant i am staying that's
a fact
i agree i would say at first too i try
to work with them if you love them
because you didn't specify when you
answered that question when you asked
that 100 pounds doesn't come on in a
week it's like the fifth is like a
[ __ ] life but there's a lot of
factors that come into that
like little to be fair like he might
have gone through depression [ __ ] a
kid a [ __ ] family member died
anything would be like to admit that but
then it's like on the way it's like okay
let's find some positive ways to
help the situation
and you want like if a family member
died you're depressed that you would
want your other your partner to stay
with you so why would you leave and
that's the thing is what we were i agree
with you is that i'm going to help you
uplift you try and get you to the best
place but if you're but if you don't
want to help yourself and you're happily
at that 100 pounds my guy you've got to
go
that is it
that hundred could be like when it hits
hundred that could be like
yeah but you can't even sing your own
things if you've got a hundred pounds
yeah because some people think that's
sexy yeah right so who are we to say
we're all quite slender like yeah i
think it just depends on who you are as
a person and what you're into like for
example a lot of the people here they
they're quite active everyone's into
sports they all play sports so you have
that kind of like you deflect what you
like about your own self about on to
other people
it's a completely different person that
you're looking at like when you say 100
pounds like especially for a woman
because obviously we have more weight
whatever mm-hmm and it could be muscle
but like if you call us
and titties or 100 pounds goes on our
ass and titties
i'm just saying i'm just hearing like
but what if what if
it was like a good way like 100 good
weight good weight she was she was
weighing out about like
[ __ ] 80 pounds on the cheeks
i don't know i'm just saying so she was
like 80 pounds she's just got she's
100 pounds and for
the goodness and greatness yeah i told
you the vision that's what i'm saying
like
they do mean something question do you
think that there
are guys that actually like bigger women
yeah yeah okay so if if so why is it
that when a man gets money and he has
more options than any other man or an
nba player whatever like
basically like the top guys when they do
get money they go for models and women
that are not plus size when they get the
choice
at that stage they go over something
different like when you've made so much
money that's why you hear about all this
like crazy like
gay [ __ ] in hollywood like no not
nothing gays let
i'm just saying like people try to just
they just do different things like
when you make so much money like money
is not an option and like you've got
hoes coming to your door like you got
man man comes like
money's not issued all right let me let
me try this let me try that out like
like there's no type at that point yeah
that's what i'm saying like when you're
hitting that like upper epsilon like it
is just different world like
if you you'll be sat wherever on like a
tuesday yeah and you've got like
40 50 of
victoria's secret models or whatever
like they all do that's what i'm saying
are they are they chubby chasers because
like like sorry
really okay do they like bigger women
because
like they actually like bigger women or
they just don't get to choose
between like they don't get the choice
for the models i hear yourself yeah so
i'm saying basically it's like so
obviously when you've got mad bread yeah
you pick all the
chubby things so you're saying some of
the
i guess like people that aren't on that
level you may see them with more
less attractive people and she's saying
is it is that more just because of
like that is what is available to you or
is that your choice as soon as you've
got more choice right that's what life
is about like if you have options like
if you're at a restaurant and you're
struggling to eat it's only you're
struggling because you have so many
options so so then could we argue that
they don't actually like overweight
women they just they just don't get the
ch they just settle because they don't
get they are 100 proof on like they're
getting chubby chubby what do you call
them i like that
they'll be cases at all times and that's
a sort of it could be life as well like
if you're let's say you grow up in in
that from like young like yeah your
parents made crazy money or they've got
like big crazy stats or whatever
from young you're growing up with this
kind of like i guess mindset of honor
you're being around a probably certain
type of crowd you're having so much
attention on yourself so maybe like your
ethics or morals are different whereas
maybe if
you was just
more like a regular regular like your
morals that you grow up with might be
different so then what you
one an epitomize and a female might be
different therefore the
that outer shell of a female may be less
important to you
because i've just never seen a guy get
money status and like things that women
like and pick the big girl i can't think
of one i don't know maybe they don't
pick him on on like in public but they
they're gonna bring it back
they're gonna bring them back like
that doesn't count like give commitment
because that's a woman want commitment i
think a lot of dudes in like the me like
because i guess the people were talking
about
a lot of celebrities or like people that
are well know i think a lot of them are
in the
media you'll see them maybe with the
model type because that's what's
portrayed in the media but i think
there's thousands behind closed doors
that are like millionaires and sports
and rare that
aren't in the media like
people that you probably don't really
know about like nba players that maybe
you don't hear about too much that their
wives are just you see a little bit
maybe not super attractive yeah
other people you've seen little doug's
first wife right the white girl i am
sorry i didn't really say but like she
is the most ugliest person that's crazy
and that's his wife bro no it's not no
like that's what i'm saying no it's baby
mom first baby and it was like a picture
from like 2013 like was he famous then
not as much but
people bring it up to this day like
so so he kind of traded up when he got
the chance that's what you're saying no
because i don't think he should have
done that in the first place i'm not
gonna lie
oh i haven't seen him i'm not the one
that did like bad things
well she he might love doing this
he might have
i ain't seen i swear to god pull up the
picture like no one's gonna say that for
sure you know when you meet someone like
africans are like that for a green card
that's the moment like that is what it
was but that's what i said like dating
the night what's the night what day is
dating what about africans
oh huh well what about africa
mic check
lightsaber
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna take a second
to read the super chats okay guys thank
you so much for the super chats you guys
have sent so far as you guys know
as you guys know um the super chats that
you send help fund this show so i have
about six months to make this like a
viable revenue stream so if you guys
want to support it and you want to keep
seeing these conversations in this type
of content it's really important that
you send super chats um okay so let me
read the ones that have been sent so far
so we got i think the first one was from
dion lewis 10 super chat in a marriage
with or without kids personal happiness
is a relevance your mates happiness is
important if they're our kid if there
are kids their success is
primary overall
um the next one five dollar super chat
again from dionne lewis no one is
completely happy their entire life
single or married you have moments of
happiness and strive to have peace in
your life
another 5.5 pounds from mr stephen men
and women are different we don't look
for the same things as you women don't
like double standards but
women don't like double standards when
it doesn't benefit them
oh boy you okay no that sounds like oh
boy that sounds like oh boy
uh dion lewis ever slayed a dragon or
two
spyro the kids
what's a dragon is that like an ugly
girl i even know i just sound funny
yeah
um okay let me see what else
um
i've asked a lot of these questions do
you think that women only like actually
that's a good one do you think women
only like double standards when or
complain about complain about double
standards when it doesn't benefit us
go ahead
like um for example one more thing like
for example um we don't see women
complaining about men not getting into
bars for free or having to not pay for
or have free drinks that's a double
standard
yeah because for me personally i feel
like
like
i want to be as equal as a
so if you're in a club and you've seen
20 you've seen guys pay like whatever
entrance right and they say oh you don't
have to pay you want to pay just because
you feel about equal standards that's a
cat i can't lie i'm not paying
you know what if i get it for free i'm
getting it for free but but if they're
telling me that i have to pay i'm not
gonna be like oh get me in free do you
know what i'm saying yeah i think when
it's in a in a setting like this yeah i
think agreed i think everyone is i'm the
anomaly type yeah but when it comes to
friday night and we're about to walk to
the club
i think i'm like
we're at the back of the line talking
about oh it's going to be
x amount to get in and they're giving it
this one oh yeah come to the front
no girl like
you choose like if a guy didn't open it
like do something like what's it called
what's that saying when something's dead
um romance not romance it's like
chivalry's dead
right what okay it's the society it
should be dead because everything's
equal i'm a king too treat me like a kid
yeah right
type of vibes i pay for men
let the girls go yeah i've paid for a
date or two
uh yeah actually yeah i
do i like to five to one ratio huh yeah
wait elaborate
he plays five times i play once
wait where's someone alright so you said
you paid for it are you playing
no but i understand no but i'm saying
like i still like to pay i make money
and i think this is the whole like
balance of women
so he didn't like like you liked him for
being ugly and funny and then you
no i've paid for dates four days you
felt some type of way though right
you're like no no no no i still put i'm
with a relationship like one day okay so
then would you pay for the second one
would you pay for the second one what
right after yeah no i think it's still
fair like what i'm spending all my
drinks like say he's going for some [ __ ]
like that but you wanted to see him
two three days
but like it's not a normal thing like
you wouldn't let her run all the way of
course
but i think the point is like you still
said five dates to one it's not equal
no it's not but i'm still putting my
hand in my pocket where some women some
some women don't some
maybe that's the people you've met so
don't be deflecting that onto this
conversation thank you no it's not
deflecting that's just okay
that's not it's not deflecting that's
just like how that's what yeah it's not
how it goes because there are a lot of
women out
on a date
prior to relationships i've actually
paid for dates and i'm like
you can't have to
your opinions don't line up with like
what we're like talking about no it does
no it don't because it does because i'm
saying i'm not i can't quantify how
because i don't even remember but i'm
saying there's actually quite a few
dates i've actually paid for like even
prior to relationship within a
relationship with those guys was it 50
50 the whole time
no no
but that's that's what i'm saying like
like again we're talking about okay you
pulled out your wallet here and there
and that's appreciated like a lot of
girls you're right like don't do that
and i think but but but it's still we're
not asking for equality here i know
girls haven't mentioned you know that
yeah we're like you're on a date or
something yeah or like you're doing
whatever it is i like let's say you've
done food drinks like you're on the
third date now we're saying so like
you've done pay first day don't paid
second day
pay for the pay for the third day now
now you move on to the next bar and
they're like
i'll get us a drink
what and then and is your turn like
they've got some four pound drink up in
tesco's and it's like yo i've reached
into my pocket now that's a joke that's
crazy it's a joke thing yeah like for me
but like again like for me that five to
one like i'm seeing that is the same
thing like yeah if you're talking
like crazy ratio like for saying like we
pay equal like yeah but i didn't say we
play equal no no but i'm saying you're
like i say i pay five one though it's
crazy like that's not even that's not
equal but i i date a guy who doesn't
want me to pay at all and this is what
the original question about stereotypes
no but he is like he's like no i should
be paying and i'm i'm finding it hard
because i'm such an independent woman
that i would always pay
in my in in different ways right and so
every guy you met like you were on a
date like you would like your mindset is
like
if i've asked you out on a date i said
yo do you want to go out how many days
do you ask out how do you want to go out
tonight you don't ask me
really and truly really and truly how
many
first day i'm not about nothing yeah
like
maybe like four five four five times
yeah four or five and i've paid for from
the room that's what i'm saying like if
a guy's asked the girls going on a date
the number is way higher okay but i'm
just saying
also it's hard women aren't it's a
stereotype but when do women ask men out
on a date like i've gone up to a guy in
a bar and said you're really cute and
then i start talking to him i'm
confident no not a lot of women are
confident my thing is the expectation
like say i take a gun on a date i would
just rather like yo even if you faking
it like i can't afford this date like
just put the put something out just
don't just sit there looking stupid no
like [ __ ] like you know what i mean just
like put it out there like
is that if you've asked them on that
date you want them to still pull out nah
like a first date yes yeah
yes regardless who has who won the day
when the bill comes if you've not even
done like a courtesy lean
i will never speak to you again big
facts
no not for all i will never like the
girl like didn't like
[Music]
because sometimes like the guy will just
like take out his card but i'm always
don't even pay for it but that's what
i'm saying like like it's a test it's a
test for guys like yeah if a girl was
like didn't say nothing i'll never i
will never meet her again i'm sneakily
paid because i know he won't let me pay
so i need to go to the toilet and i'll
sneak a little bit like we said it was
the um what'd you call it the gesture
like from a guy's point of view but but
we're kind of going back back to the
original question like we have all these
we have we have a we have a [ __ ] march
for women you've never heard of that
that much like that's so so we complain
about the double standard we have a slot
of like the the body count thing right
like that's a double standard and women
will complain and they'll go
like like men have a higher body count
they don't get they don't get oh yeah
like yeah but women
yeah yeah and so
wow okay okay but i'm saying like like
so there are marches for that like we
have i don't know if you've heard of
this but there's like a [ __ ] march in
california
women will say oh let's own the word and
we'll complain for days about that but
we don't see women marching the streets
for men to pay equal or to you know get
into bars for free or anything else
themselves no
no no
women i can do it
you know
what i'm saying i'm saying
women women complain about like we want
equality but we only want equality when
it benefits us
like where where's the equality for why
don't women lined up to be plumbers
i feel like we are fighting like as a as
a as a woman yeah we fight for our own
stuff does that make sense so i feel
like if men want it like they should the
equal bar thing they should fight for it
themselves because you know what
especially we live in a world where men
get a lot of more privileges like okay
cool yeah we get into bars and stuff
that's fair enough but there's a lot of
stuff where men are more superior to
women and that's one thing they get paid
more than a dollar no no no no no no
just you and what like jobs like
especially
in terms of like jobs i feel like men
get ra men get a lot more respect
okay but it's true it is true though
respect
even in sport okay cool men get a lot of
more like respect in terms of that a lot
more credit a lot more props a lot more
leeway advantage
but how is it how is it how is that true
when women have specific grants like
there are specific grants only for women
not given to men on top of that on top
of that and there are quotas so they
have to get a certain amount of women in
a job but when a field is is female-led
there's no quota for men so how so yeah
so how is how is there how
i feel like women are already fighting a
battle in itself so the money situation
itself like women get paid less to the
dollar to the to the man right but how
do you know how do you know that we're
paid less because we're women i mean
you're the stats ladies because you're
going out in the profession like if
you're going to be an engineer like
there's not a lot of female in the only
but even when it comes to sports right
the only sport that is paid the exact
same money though no but i'm saying oh
tennis but yeah let's finish it
that's because respectfully i know you
men are better than women at sports
sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry you're probably you you
specific you're probably better than
most men but in general like most men in
the nba can dunk wnb can't
and they and they get paid more because
they make more money like that like
women's ncaa has been at a loss for
years they don't even make money
why is that because because people don't
watch as much because it's just not as
entertaining who's i don't even keep who
runs the show who who's the top dog the
man because every time you know what you
know like no like about like oh
i swear
i was like if i really want to watch a
women's game like i would watch a
women's game like that when it gets to
like
certain levels like finals semi-finals i
like i was here but like
this is like and i'm a sports person so
like imagine people like that aren't
like it's sad it's sad because listen if
i was a woman i would [ __ ] hate men
i'd be like the feminists like
slew them
but it's like it is like it is always
like on an individual level what we're
going to do is the people
just one second just that fact in itself
what you're saying you know i mean and
that is why there's those women groups
because of these situations it's so hard
for us to get jobs and then you add
race into it you add where you live
ethnicity all these things are so
difficult so yeah there are only women
clubs there are only women gyms oh no
there's nothing because there's dirty
old men who wank in the corner
that comes into that yeah there's these
things all put in for women because for
so many years they've been
suppressed devalued
like how are we devalued we got to stay
at home and not work that [ __ ] sounds
awesome
though yeah joe is he fighting with a
squirrel no but but i'm saying like like
like even even the women but that was
only that came from like the war days
where the women had jobs in the war and
then the men came home and then they
took those women's jobs so then they got
put back in the home of now you have to
live well
like historically men had to fight in
wars so how can we say we were oppressed
we never had to fight in wars no but i'm
saying prison
again they gain control
and then also and even and even let's
talk about the pay gap like the reason
that when men are paid more than women
is because they pick industries that
make more money so like like if you go
to the most egalitarian countries in the
world where women have more choice
the the pay gap is bigger
because
men choose like professions with objects
where women's women choose professions
with people
no but i'm asking like like our
automatic gut reaction is always that
like it's about male and female
but like how do you know it's not just
the industries we pick
no for sure industry like industry is a
big thing
for you
now go ahead i've spoken my my part yeah
i agree with her a lot i can't lie um i
feel like there's just a lot of factors
like you can say okay cool like men get
to go work and the women get to stay at
home and it's all fun but it's not all
fun and games a lot of those women are
abused they're treated like crap like
that but why are they controlled but why
is that your immediate like like i just
don't understand why that's your
immediate gut reaction is to say like
they're at home because they're
controlled and they're abused and all
that stuff like i know what i'm asking
is that is that your your your view on
men it's just that you think the
majority of men are like abusing their
women no but i think a lot of those
women are unhappy and it comes from the
old school days like where they're
actually suppressing they're kind of
taught they're brought into that
tradition and it just continues where a
lot of those women actually are unhappy
and they would like to speak out and
that's
like if your mom raised you like yo
don't chase [ __ ] from no man
like you would move completely different
cultures though different colors
i'm saying she says all this culture i'm
like bro it depends on like who you've
been raised by like some families invite
this something but that's right that's
where zania was like that's where race
comes into ethnicity a lot of those
things come like they're big factors
like we can all talk about the
positivity but there are other sides
like we're here to have a discussion on
all those different types of views so we
can't just say oh like yeah there's all
those women are happy but not all those
women are happy a lot of them
why is that your assumption how do you
know we don't but that is yeah but you
also see it from one
um perspective
in america so you only see one way so
you don't really see how the other
different ethnicities different cultures
have completely their women have to stay
at home that is you're saying that's
really cool but as women
we're starting to we want to be ceos we
want to be pushing
of men and this is what she's saying as
a young woman is saying like actually no
i would like to pay i would but do i
have the opportunities to make the same
money but i'm saying like like if that's
true like why in the countries where
women have more choice than ever is the
pay gap bigger so you can you can make a
list of countries right where women are
the most depressed and the least
depressed and the pay gap grows when
women have more choice
because of the industries they pick but
a lot of men so i'm not even talking
about other factors i'm just talking
about like male and female go ahead so a
lot of men do run those industries
though that determine those pays like a
lot of men even that they're very biased
in terms of like even internal
promotions and stuff within companies
but they can't change a pay grade like
of like yo you're a man
but i'm saying to to offset that we have
quotas so there are like i worked in
copier sales for two years that's a very
male dominated industry it's [ __ ] it's
awful
oh my god
and they couldn't get women to stay
because it was terrible like it's a like
those those jobs are working 80 90 hours
a week my dad worked 80 hours a week my
whole life
i do you want i don't want to work 80
hours a week i don't know many girls
that do there's a lot of women that
actually are out there like even in a
lot of countries like they're working a
lot they're working like two free jobs
just to keep it yeah but i'm saying but
i'm saying if that's true then why in
the countries where they have the most
choice to do that do less women
like like you know we're all wealthy
like what's the difference so i'm saying
like like you go to the countries where
women have more choice an opportunity to
do those things and they choose not to
why if women want to i think it's just a
lot to do with like history as well
though like you're stuck in a phase so
maybe women i i'm not saying women don't
make there's a lot of women that make
stuff harder for themselves like we do
all have a choice but there's a lot of
circumstances that dictate that like we
can even go back i don't know this is
relevant but it actually makes sense to
me like the whole molly may like we all
have 24 hours in a day like we actually
don't have the same 24 hours in a day
like everyone's circumstance is actually
different everyone finds it okay
there's so many factors that come into
that like like culture like everything
like it's just the opportunities don't
actually get given like as much as you
think they do that's a race thing it's
not like a gender thing for sure like
it's not just it's not just race though
like there's a lot of caucasian women
that face those issues
disability like there's a lot of like
other other factors but i'm saying like
just pure gender like
but then if you're like you would never
you wouldn't reject a job for like a
woman
over a man because you saw the name if
they had the same skills like
well and the other question is like why
aren't we rallying like we'll talk about
ceo and power positions but why aren't
we talking about women not wanting to be
things like garbage collectors plumbers
like all the hard jobs in the in the
military
like it's always like that's what i'm
saying we only kind of like there's a
there's a lot of women in the military
but they get treated like absolute [ __ ]
they don't get paid you know women
though you know i don't know any man
i don't know any women plumbers but i
know a navy person and he they
disrespect women like nothing they treat
them like [ __ ] and he's a high-ranking
person no that's not i don't know i'm i
don't like it and so it's hard to be
this but then there's also it's like
okay there's not men beauticians like
there's this job there's just gender
jobs that just like uh we're trying to
break off why can't there be a woman
plumber why can't there be a man who
does my eyelashes
there's not enough man be like yo i want
to do eyelashes and then it's like
but this is why like i'm going back to
the same question where it's like we're
complaining about inequality when it
doesn't like benefit us
or when it we complain about inequality
but only like we only complain about the
ones that don't benefit us like we don't
we don't rally the same way always be
intrigued to like hear this like really
intruder like because obviously you like
for women you're fighting for like
yourself like
and i like i said i'll be the same way
if i was a woman i would hate me
but i'm saying like for the ones that
benefit you right but are you rallying
are you rallying because you're paying
to get into clubs not everyone's
rallying yo not every girl's right out
here rallying like no but i'm just
saying i'm saying you no are you i don't
mind them coming together like i'm sick
of paying 100 pounds
it's not about rally it's about sharing
your opinion like oh yo these are gonna
be in for free like whatever that you
can't say that about guys you can't like
you know what i mean like you're
contradicting yourself there because she
did she just asked you a question and
said but are you valiant i'm not gonna
rally because
[Applause]
there's a guy that probably went to that
rally that is just going because his
wife's there
like it's not like they care like it's
just like if it affects you
then you would you would have a reason
like for women's rights like it's very
different because if it affects you then
men are being thrown off like their
phone like
object like you know i mean in the
background like they're going to be like
just think stereotypes you're right
every each gender picks which one
affects them which one they want to care
about which i i mean i've had
relationships where it's really
affecting me i'm like why can you do
this and i can't do this like and i
think maybe in sporting world also like
we're in a very oh i think most women
but we're in a very man like driven
indus yeah dominated sports so now
though
no and it's like and it is frustrating
i'm sure it's frustrating to you too
like i wish women were paid more in
sports it's ass like i mean you probably
actually make decent i know people don't
even like watching women's sport or
don't believe in it like yeah i've had
like a top like top top guy say to me
yeah we just come for the drinks and the
party for the women like you lot are
just our social club big boy i'm talking
like
top top top
level and just said to me not our
country but just said like yeah i just
come for the bands like i just come to
see the women play and have a drink with
my mates like we don't respect it and if
the top men are talking like that how do
you think it then affects how do you
think it trickles down
you don't think there's a talent
difference in men and women and like
like basketball
okay who's the better team london lions
women or men
you know if we played you we're better i
i think we praise you i played you
but if you if
men and women in like sports personally
basketball because i'm a basketball
player myself and i love watching
basketball i feel like men play with
pride and women play as a team that's
what i think okay so if you're not
allowed if you're not allowed to dunk
if you know yo
listen listen listen listen if you're
not allowed to dunk
and we pl we should do this
everybody on that day let's i think we
should do it you know i think we should
do it
i think we should do it
dude if you're not generally thinking
like yo i could beat them in a minute no
one is going on julian like no one will
no no no no you really think you'd be
our team like well not in a full game
what fight like a minute like no no no
like not to eleven like whatever
every single time but even though that's
what you're saying
[Music]
you still have to put a handicap on them
so they don't beat you like you still
have to say
okay you can dunk like but i'm saying i
love it it'll be quite fun
i would like to it'll be fun everywhere
i'm live streaming on my channel
play for my heart do you remember that
love of basketball yeah
11-0 i feel like men's physiology is a
bit different for to women so they could
last a bit long like it's something that
i've had to grow up and like like me
when i was younger i'm like i'm better
than guys what are you talking about but
obviously you had to grow up realizing
that yeah they're stronger than me
they're faster than me they have a sec i
don't know what it's called but they can
last longer in a game
more than women but
but i feel like when it comes to
entertainment entertainment-wise they
can be better but i'll if personally as
a basketball player i'd rather watch a
woman's game but but like you realize
like the results kind of speak for
themselves by who who views what for
example we have like athleticism all
that kind of stuff it's nice
it's not it's not like a fun reality i
don't enjoy this like i wish i wish i
could make more money playing volleyball
it just is what it is i can't i can't
not see what it is i wish
[Music]
i think we should make it happen i think
it'll be fun
i'll work for coaches
only like
only five minutes that's all we need
five minutes you need i think something
honestly you need one second that's the
only time it's like i'm telling you like
just a shot like get off the tape got my
shot
you're lying you're not that's what i'm
saying one at a time
i think the girl's got it you're lying
like truly though you're lying no
they're good
they are a great team like they are a
great team but honestly you're lying to
yourself yo serena williams right best
woman tennis player ever played the game
ever again
[Music]
no listen listen listen that's what i'm
saying listen so she said she was the
best like we all know she's the goat
like serena williams
she said she would not be in the top 500
of men because of the like because there
was an argument like oh she might be a
man that uh it was just like physical
like it's like
that's why they play three games and
that's why everyone's playing no it's
about one game no no i'm saying women
play three games men pay five so that's
what she's talking about the x but like
no no wait if she played five there's
there's still no chance no i that's what
we're saying well also
once this goes into the fact of
men are different women we're two
different species as humans that's why
there's double standard that's why men
can do something women can't you don't
have to pay for the club we don't have
there's so many why would you think you
could beat us in basketball i just
wanted to get a conversation
i wound you up didn't it
and i was on fire i still do i feel like
you would beat us 100 you would beat us
uh seven to eleven
but i thought when i when i watched
[Music]
please tell me
please tell me
if it was if it was me if it was me like
i'll take myself out of it so i tried to
be less biased well you've got one hand
cast playing without if he's playing
what's up
yeah but if you're let's say we got how
much we putting up you guys win but how
many do we put up
three i think if you if i think i think
there's a chance you like whatever shot
you're putting up is a hail mary to be
honest i think it's like wow it's a
random three and if it goes in it goes
in you're posting up someone that's
seven foot and you've never done it in
your life yes there's no girl that at
seven foot
[Music]
when i see women's women play they use
more of their heads
come on let's do it for themselves
between having to do all these eloquent
moves or just bodying someone i would
just pick the best
to like i would like he's physical as
[ __ ] he like my game that is just like
mad physical and i don't think
i could do i could i would be able to do
that that's facts that's [ __ ] like
he's like the master plays like that
like if you do that to a woman like
it's not the same
anyway
yeah what's the next one
soon to come um i'm going to read the
super chat
yeah
i don't think you're a better iq i'm not
saying i'll say like people have it
similar i wouldn't say like just because
maybe you guys can't play above them i
won't say you guys have necessarily like
better iq i think there's guys
like on the team that have do have
higher consent and i think there's go
and there's girls on your team that also
have a higher cube i wouldn't say like
you guys have
like better iq how many people have
really real like obviously you've been
playing for a long time
playing players like you know but you
know basketball no i'm saying like so
like obviously you have iq of the game
but it's how many times like how many
others that's something like well no no
no we got like really intruded like a
guy on our team he's 23 24.
he
he has iq of the game he knows the game
like that's
our starting point like
but like if you like
trying to pick him out like it wouldn't
be the same like you just see his game
and it translates like
like people taught the talk but like
we're seeing it well i think it'll be
fun at the end of season i'm a referee
okay i'll i'll make it my youtube i'll
make it a youtube
we can test it um okay i'm gonna read
some super chats um i call
sentience i don't know if that's your
name but i literally will call you daddy
if you keep sending super chats like
this i swear to god
look at it you don't even understand
this man sent a 500 super chat once
my favorite super chatter okay as for
women getting paid more women choose
jobs that are less dangerous work less
hours and thank you for bringing up race
in the workplace we now have compliance
companies who fire men and hire women
for the political image not because of
merit fifty dollars thank you so much
next super chat also from sentience for
the soccer debate u.s men women's teams
the male team makes more because they
bring in more views and money
furthermore if the women's team can't
beat 15 year old boys how do they claim
they're better than men all jobs are
performance based not feelings
100 super chats from zantians you are my
favorite thank you
um
i think two dollars from dion
the pay
the pay gap has been been debunked a
thousand times sentience to the women
who said men get more stuff she has no
idea what she's saying men earn respect
but women demand it further more women
gain huge advantages in court child
support false claims
um
then
um
5.5 pounds from if i read this i don't
know i'm gonna read it again men and
women are different we don't look for
the same things as you do women don't
like the double standards um don't oh
this is what started this conversation
okay
um
okay
oh i did not
i did not i was shout out to them that
was really nice of them first of all
everyone who who donated oh yeah no he's
my
he said daddy he's a dad like okay i
swear i'll keep add me on instagram
hello no no not today he has though
today
no this is a different this is a
different thing
we appreciate them yeah we cause no for
real guys like these super chats keep
this stuff going again i have in six
months i have to make this profitable
and in order for it to be profitable you
guys have to keep sending donations so i
really appreciate it when you guys fund
this type of content um
yeah so thank you
okay um it was a great last company
that's what i was gonna do last
it's interesting we went
okay um next question
as
do you guys feel like okay because this
kind of reminds me of this conversation
this question for the boys do you feel
like men and women like if a guy says
something like it comes off differently
than if a girl says the same thing so
it's kind of like you guys are hearing
me talk
and you say it's like weird hearing this
come from a girl
like do you feel like an example i like
it like if we talk about the pay gap
like if a girl talks about it versus a
man do you think people receive it
differently
i'd respect i'm like yo you're educated
like we're having this grown-ass
conversation
i would feel that way no do you feel
like women listen to other women more or
they think they listen to men more or do
you not see a difference i think i think
i listen to other women more but i feel
like just natural just based on like
if they're a guy said they might just
think
like i'm not saying these are my beliefs
or whatever but if if a guy was saying
like oh i think like women shouldn't get
paid anything guys should get paid a lot
like obviously like a girl's gonna be
like
oh you're
just like uh
some any man where if a girl says it
because i think they've got similarities
in that sense there's going to be more
like questions that's more like
reason for like wanting to understand
like why they might feel that way
yeah is there something you guys want to
say you keep looking at each other
i'm just saying like as an extreme yeah
is there something you guys want to say
i could i could see the world i think
more just like
whoever is
more credible at the table i don't care
if it's a woman or a man like
but you say no it's not even about
taking out it's just like
uh advice it's
whatever life
if if you're a woman and you're telling
me you need to do this
i'm listening to it if you're a guy
because you i a woman can't give me a
man's perspective and vice versa
but but i'm just saying in the fact of
if we're at a table and you're
you know what you you're talking about
you're
good at your job or even basketball you
telling me josie you should set the
screen and then turn and look i'm going
to say thank you very much
you
in a gym one day i said you lot are
[ __ ] rude i said you come in here
every day
bro
what the [ __ ] you don't tell me good
morning
like you know everyone's like you're the
oldest like she made sense
i didn't know he was there though no no
because you know when he was like and
the girls team like hey what's up
whatever and she was like hey how's your
morning i was like oh
no no no no no no they walked in like
slapped asses yeah didn't you say
nothing i lost and she was like yo
you lot don't say nothing hotted him up
right and so what he's going to listen
to me and go
and he was respectful and he said you
know what i'm going to tell the lads
thank you very much that's so
appreciative no stop it don't no no no i
respected it i was like you know what
like fair play like
and i'm not you know what i mean and i
didn't even know each other i didn't
know no i mean fair play i don't know
him i just hotted him up and he
respected it
you know that's what i'm saying in the
room it doesn't matter that was the
first bridge of communication before
like
being like what men's and women's team
talk you were like you know walk walking
here after you take a l you kind of say
good morning to me like no because we
say like hi or whatever i was like i was
like right like are you talking are you
talking on the channel who pause what
you're like you're just like no i was
just no no i was like i said like i said
like what's up like when she was like no
you didn't say like what's good i was
like i hear what you're saying like
it should be impolite we practice if we
practice on the same core like
like we have interaction we are like
completely strangers but the example of
it doesn't matter
[Music]
[Music]
shut the [ __ ] up is that what you're
saying well come to me to write
no i was
respectfully disrespectful
so when you know she or the hunt the
whole show was like so you don't make so
um
[Music]
i know you in it and i know like if i
heard that story if i heard that story
no one knew like there's no way i would
have thought that would run
like no way nah she was like so you can
lose but you can't say good morning that
was it like and then i was like damn you
right like good morning i'm sorry i'll
and she was like you just said it's the
first time you said no no
no no i didn't know i didn't know you
before that no but i'm saying like the
the question after that was like why
didn't you say good morning it must have
been on a good moon
but it was more like no i get what she's
saying like we're in the same building
we're practicing the same gym it's like
why would i say like i know
it's mannerism
yeah i know she's like i gotta speak to
no one i don't i don't know
which i completely understand like i'm
the same but i just feel like i think in
terms of what she was addressing like is
like a little boy told me that i'll be
like shut the [ __ ] up like it's
different but i was her point you're
actually supporting my point there she
was just saying like in terms of how a
girl would approach like it's different
like two like men and women provide
different things and that's okay she
asked me when i get my
they're all being rude i'm like
i'm gonna say good morning i'm sorry
about that and then i'll tell the boys
she's holding me up that's just a prime
example because obviously you're across
from me but i'm just saying in general
whatever workplace outside whoever is
yeah it applies that message never got
passed on no because really because i
knew how you were as a person not i
didn't know but i was like when you say
that to someone like you mean it like yo
[ __ ] relay that message and i was
like
okay she's addressing me in a certain
way i'm like i'll be like yo
she said good morning [ __ ]
what was it was it more like you didn't
say no just because you were more
shocked yeah i was just more surprised
no i didn't i would never say that but
like she surprised me like yo go say
morning
because you seem really shocked
shut the [ __ ] up
it depends obviously i wasn't there so i
can't say but if like from what it what
it sounds like if the energy wasn't
right and then i'll slap back with that
same energy but it wasn't crazy though
why is his name
from
this is what i've understood that before
this youtube didn't particularly know
each other they hadn't particularly
spoken yeah that was the first time we
spoke right if that's the first time i
spoke like i've i'm not really like a
a crazy social person i don't really
know you like i'm not i'm not i knew she
was the older like you go like you know
what i mean a little bit like respect on
her yeah
everyone's different but me if i don't
really know you like that like
you know who they are lies in like
you know what i mean like a dude like
all right yeah sorry for no i'm not
black good no like you know who they are
i'm like you don't
know them you know like it's more like
you said you know who's saying who then
is more like yeah
okay
exactly so like now like the women's
team whatever like there's certain girls
like i know they're from like history or
whatever like and some of them are i'll
say like yo what's good like you're all
right and some of them like i'll if i'm
walking by and i doubt that though i
won't speak
she's demanding that respect because why
not you guys do play for this like same
like she demanded another like she was
like i was walking away
and she was like yo and she took control
of that narrative and she set the tone
which is as she should
but
that's the exact situation
like i spoke to someone else whatever i
walked in but i said
you're gonna say hello anybody like you
maybe like hey i'm sorry that whatever
and then
just confused what happened i think a
lot i think i think i lost it there's
one trying space so basically
i came we like we practiced on the same
chord okay at one point and like we
don't normally do that really like
obviously call whatever
and then from there
i walked into the gym and she was like
yo
you're gonna say good morning like you
said that yeah like also i'm growing up
like but i knew who she was she might
know who i was like possible why
and then she was like yo you ain't gonna
say good morning like after you take a
loss like what's wrong with you like no
one likes and i was like
that's why i would have like if it was i
thought different like i would have
understood like damn but i was like
she's right i just went to the point of
what we talked about it doesn't matter
if you're a man or a woman how are you
come across okay no no not even coming
across it's i can take it from a man or
i can take it from a woman it was just a
prime example because i didn't know him
but i said to him hey you are coming in
here with a slapped up like yeah no i
like that i was like yo that's my
presence i was like hell yeah so and he
respected me as a woman and maybe
i'm i'm more superior than him and
that's a hard no
straight up that's hard to take it look
he's going to choke but in the industry
of course you know i mean
i'm sorry i've done more than you and
i've achieved more than you you will get
you will you will get to that point
where you will surpass me but right now
that's where i am so but this goes back
to the point is i'm the ceo of this
moment yeah so what he didn't respect me
he respected me yeah and he relayed the
message it's hard for him to take it
because it's hurting his pride for me to
say i'm the one no i know but i'm just
explaining to you how do i understand
that i understand what you're saying you
know what i'm saying i'm not i i just
told you so i'm not hearted no no no he
doesn't understand i uh
[Music]
i can't speak because obviously it
wasn't me so like that's other people's
progressives like whatever they're doing
and then but
that's saying that
i wasn't there sorry like i don't know
the exact situation but the situation
i'm hearing like
i don't feel like you can't take it i
have i have an off-topic question for
the for the men okay
do you think it's confusing for men when
they don't know how many dates they have
to take a girl on to get sex
nope
there was the only time i've been told
about like this date like like you don't
think it's confusing how what does that
mean the same is it the same object like
let me tell you for real
so
men that meet someone they'll have sex
at any point like
but when they say like oh a five five
date like whatever
they're gonna go to them five days and
act the same that they would have had
like beforehand so it doesn't matter how
like you how long you put it out for
blah blah blah blah blah
it's like
that's i respect to girl more if like
you're like i'm gonna have sex with you
cool like and then from there i'm gonna
like
treat you no i've just i've just was
thinking of double standards and like
because you guys kind of exchange your
resources in exchange for like sex at
some point
right would you agree or disagree like
men in general uh yeah i've heard i've
heard it kind of been said like that
before
no
carry on
read it whatever that is read it it's
not reading it's fine
yeah i've heard him said like that
before i guess the resources i'm men of
is more fun so i've just i've just heard
like men get confused because they're
like well like they never know how long
they have to wait and like so like no i
think people are different like there's
gonna be people out there that i'll
probably you know be like i'll probably
need to wait for the third day that i
don't need to do it that's quite
old-school ways is it
as women i'm not i'm not like oh he has
to take me out on five dates or like six
days i don't know is that is that even a
woman like you would have sex like if
you felt like that everything was good
though what you would have sex on the
first date because you're like you feel
like having sex on the first date yeah
is that a thing anymore and maybe i'm a
bit older then um like oh we have to
have this many days it's definitely a
thing that's a question to you pearl
how many dates do you need to smash
[Music]
bro
um well my last boyfriend we were dating
so like how many dates did you take down
i don't
oh gosh that was a different situation
but do you have a number on you no it's
not a number because it kind of depends
where i met you like yeah because for me
like it takes me a second to feel like
comfortable i guess
so it's like if i met you
through like mutual friends it'd
probably take less time than if i met
you on like an app because i have to
make sure you're not going to kill me
you know
yeah so but as a young girl do you have
a number in your head i just want to
know how the dating like no
for me i'm not do you have a number in
your head no because basically i've been
in a six-year relationship so i'm not
really in the day and i don't really
know how it works on the date good for
you
congratulations yeah
we love him or her whatever nobody oh
you're still in a relationship yeah oh
say listen i thought you meant like you
should i was like what are we
congratulating for last night
i feel like when i was younger it was
like oh yeah we like because all these
rules that you used to hear but it's
just like
i'm a big advocate on maybe not the show
but like with your friends and your
girlfriends you should talk about your
sex life right what happens what pops up
i wonder i would never know that though
this is why i think you should because
the only
aspect of sex that we get is porn and
porn isn't real so if i don't speak to
my fellow friends or girlfriends or
teammates
effectively like like personally like
okay like you tell your boy or your girl
how great your sex life was like boom
boom boom
girlfriend oh yeah no i'm talking about
your nose
like your closest friends whatever right
so like they they hear about every how
everything is great but i had my best
friend i was never like i was like never
thought this would happen i'm in america
like never
he moves to my girl only because of like
what he's heard how how good
i'm saying no bro that's it that's what
happens on a right no girl man
but unless you happen this weekend i'm
trying to tell you that like
as in someone i'm trying to no that [ __ ]
happens for a while that's crazy i just
feel like that person wasn't your friend
because me personally i talk about the
my sex because she's my she's my friend
outside of here right and i talked to
her about my sex life like on a regular
occasion yes then because then you know
what's healthy you know what yeah i had
i had a friend who was getting choked
right okay cool that's sexy but she was
going to a point where she was like
passing out but she didn't exactly
you're laughing at that but she didn't
she's young right this is my like
freshman sophomore year in college she
didn't she don't know but if she don't
have this safe space conversation where
you say actually babe you know what that
this is that sexy and that can happen
but this is too far but if you saw that
in porn which is
oh [ __ ] when she passed out like five
times what the [ __ ] is going on who says
it's too far but she thinks that it it's
okay like okay maybe that's wait wait
it's not too far for you she likes
yeah she does she doesn't that's what
i'm saying i'm saying as of the open
conversation she said that she didn't
know it was no other option like she
just thought that was the only thing and
that's why i'm saying having the
conversation
but that's only in her head so if you
have these open conversations you you
guys don't you
you have the pride thing because now
you're saying if i like passing out i
would tell someone
do not [ __ ] make me pass out bro i'll
be like yo like do this do that like but
she said vulnerable six months i mean
like oh my god like i don't actually
like this because you're a man no sick
it's not the same can i ask you
something okay cool say that's your
sister you don't know about it
[Music]
just hear my question because i want to
give you a different point of view yeah
yeah i'm going to say your point of view
is wrong but i'm thinking i'm giving you
a different perspective that's your
sister since she's getting choked by her
her partner and she's passing out do you
think that's okay from your perspective
cause you've all seen it on a
perspective where you're choking
okay cool you're taking your girl to the
point she's passing out but she's so
valuable she's gonna ask my girl what
she's into my sister like what she's
into like it's not anything
what we're trying to say is there needs
to be a safe space where your sister can
talk that's on her and the man
feels safe because you can be in
relationships like that where you don't
feel safe to tell it's a different
question
listen listen it might not even be a
safe thing she might not even know
especially
wait wait wait if this i said she was
young she's a sophomore she's a rookie
right if this is your first sexual
relationship and you're with a guy it
could be the other way around right i'm
gonna tell her like quite like she's
gonna see me as i'm older like i'm i'm
like this is what i'm saying you're
saying well how do you know she doesn't
like it because it's her only
her only experience are you gonna put it
it doesn't even have to be bad stuff it
could be new stuff that you haven't
tried and then you bring it to the table
you're like yo you did what okay i'm
gonna try it with my man so it doesn't
necessarily have to be negative stuff of
choking or whatever but it might be
you've never been choked and you're like
bring it to the table
you guys said girls are going to talk to
each other
i have a question i have a question for
the guys do you feel like guys share
more what they do with their friends
about girls that are more casual and
share less with their friends about
girls that they're serious about they
really don't mind so you're saying guys
don't talk you don't no neither of you
know anything about each other's sex
life no yeah oh no it will be what you
said like if it's
it was like the
uh
outsides of non-relationships like we
used to talk all the time but i'll never
like sarah like chat to him about what
me and my girl like yeah yeah
like he talked to me i was in a
relationship and then he's been on the
back end relationship like we don't like
oh what do you do last night like it's
different but i smell like with the
random ass or like we have a party or
whatever but we talk about them like not
about us we talk about like how they
behave like because really intriguing
like
this is what i'm saying like really and
truly if i was ever going to go on a
date with a girl that i took seriously i
will never tell my amanda about that
i'll be like this is because like this
is my feelings this is my life because
of your experience has some guy
yeah because he stole your girl no
this is a gender difference because
women value relationships more and we
bond like like we i mean i feel like
half the women reason girls bond is like
we talk about guys
that's what we're doing
but but but like like for and the same
thing with what you're talking about
with like she couldn't say no because
women tend to be more agreeable than men
like that we were standard deviations
also she doesn't know any better oh yeah
so that's what i'm saying if you have
these open conversations
but no but i'm saying like like this is
a gender difference what we're talking
about here because he's saying well why
wouldn't you just say something because
that's a man's response like if a man
doesn't like something she's going to be
so humorous no but but it's not like no
no no
women are more aggressive
like conflict as much as men
so men are more direct and that's a
gender difference
like so that's like that's why when you
you're talking right now you're like i
don't i don't get it why don't you just
say something no i do not know all the
girls kind of understand like what
you're talking about yeah yeah right
right i'm just saying most things should
be brought to the table of different
fun bad good left right what you like
because the porn side of things have
affected especially men okay yes women
watch porn but men have indulged in it
and it's skilled your mind of numbing it
said you cheated like you had to overrun
listen you never said nothing so like
what's that gonna do with
brothers talking about huh what is that
no dude like we're doing something about
like pornhub or whatever like that's not
let's start like that's so irrelevant
there's no correlation there by the way
thank you
i just didn't understand what that had
to do with the conversation it's fine
he's like i [ __ ] just eyed her for no
reason yeah
no he's at me because i told him about
himself in practice one time
no i [ __ ] put that one to everyone
else i was like yo she did a great job
i'm kidding i just think i i mean
whatever maybe it is that you're right
about girls and a boy's situation but
maybe men need to talk about it more
maybe with women instead of men because
they can't trust men and i don't know i
feel like there's also to immense inc in
capability of talking about emotions and
certain feelings because i feel like
compared to women women are more open
about talking about feelings
um compared to men where men are like
more closed off and
he doesn't need any more like
like more more like more like back on it
like like they don't they hold
themselves back on that yeah whereas
maybe this is like the opportunity to be
like
do you know
do you know what thing
do you know what like yeah you should
have need to be bi
okay dude i don't know um yeah so it's
like that's what that's so that's what i
think you're trying to say right like
men like men should talk about whereas
with women i think that's why even men
get annoyed like oh you're talking about
talking to your friend about your
relationship problems and they're giving
you advice and they always blame the
friend whereas with men like they don't
they just think on their own but it's
like you could actually talk to your
friend about and you could probably get
gain a better perspective but you didn't
you chose to hold it in and then you see
your point of view and that's actually
messed you up
oh i will i don't know
but that's just half like i think that's
just a lot with i have male friends and
like no i yeah
what'd you say what did you say sorry
because it was irrelevant again okay
okay well um i think that was my last
question for everyone um
i know sometimes these conversations can
be like uncomfortable but i really
appreciate all of you all of you coming
it wasn't uncomfortable it was quite
good you've been a great host
yeah yeah yo there's no bad breeze like
we were just in our opinion
are we we're not beefin
i'm sorry i'm sorry i said men are
better than women i'm sorry
i'm sorry that's probably the only
comment that i didn't
i didn't hear that i know i said i was
like this is the wrong person
everyone's friends um
but what i'd like to do is um i'd like
to go around everyone you can put in
your closing thoughts that you had about
the conversation and let the people know
where they can find you
we start here listen i have no bad
opinions on anyone that said anything
we're cool
i have my outlandish opinions cool i got
nothing against it i respect everyone's
opinion
j.o.j.o underscore spencer instagram
[Music]
i still think that women are
better up here in sports than men you
didn't say it no i didn't say that i
didn't say that
i said that i said that
everyone's built different they're
raised different their mentality is
different like
like all their surroundings so each and
everyone's opinion is valued regardless
but yeah guys follow me on instagram
wait what if you're into like fashion
and design that'd be great thanks
i said what i said
that's it really josh ward jaywald
hibber j w a-r-d-h-i-b-b-e-r-t
twitter
instagram is all the same
i have my own mic
[Music]
um i think these conversations are so
important uh
through women men ages um different
races and whatever ethnicities i think
it's so important to bring it to the
table because we all learnt something
new today and our mindset has changed
just a little bit and
this is what these things are so
important so i respect it and if you
have anything else to say to me follow
me at
azania13 a-z-a-n-i-a
on instagram there is no this is my this
is my moment to shine
no i'm
guys guys all of the links to their
instagrams except for hermiones
i know what
yeah you said hermione i always do
um um is in the description it was only
because you said you didn't want your
instagram in the description because my
instagram's private yeah
loki and whatnot
um before i end the stream guys thank
you so much for the super super chat a
special thanks to the